individualism
for me is not the way it's set up in
this society some sort of antithesis
to the government
i think an immense con has been pulled
on the american people
and the khan works like this
you know what's bad and what's dangerous
and threatens you
it's the government the government's
going to come in and tell you what to do
the government's going to run your life
the government's the problem there
really is no other way to explain the
following in american politics
large numbers of people lose their homes
in a downturn like the so-called great
recession of 2008.
who do they blame
the government
large numbers of people go unemployed
and what is the media all about the
government
if i were a capitalist i'd love this
i kicked the workers by throwing them
out of their home and they don't get
angry at me they get angry the
government
i fire large numbers of people i have no
responsibility for what happens to them
as a result of having no job and no
income and they get angry at the senator
i'm laughing all the way to the bank
this is a genius stroke in theory but
if you look at government because you
said accountability and the capitalist
system has no accountability there's
some pushback i give on the
accountability i think there is some
accountability work can discuss in a
hegelian way who
there's more accountability
uh for i would say that in theory
government is perfectly accountable
that's the whole point of a democratic
system
is you vote people in in practice right
there's a giant growing bureaucracy
that is accountable only on the surface
there's two parties
that seems the same are the same media
somehow
integrated into making the the the same
two parties that are just wearing
different colored shirts
uh to seem like they're very opposed and
are arguing and bitterly arguing and
calling each other's
spouses nasty names and all those kinds
of things okay but that's government
so
uh
what exactly is worse
government or or companies well why are
we asking that question well
these are twins
what you were able to say about
republicans and democrats just now with
which i agree yeah i would say the same
thing about corporations and the
government this is the same people
literally let's go to churchill which
one is the which one of course let's go
to churchill like democracy is the worst
form of government except all the other
ones or whatever so this kind of same
idea
which one exactly is worse because to me
it seems like which one between
government and uh industry and companies
it's because government is plagued by
um
i would call it corruption because the
corruption of
bureaucratic paperwork and then because
but they're not accountable there
doesn't seem to be a serious
accountability again
we're not seeing we're not living on the
same planet
the greatest practitioners of central
planning
are corporations
elon has an
operation like general motors ford ibm
or any of the other mega corps they have
to plan
they buy up companies
because they don't want to deal in the
market they don't want the insecurity
the uncertainty of having to buy their
inputs
or sell their outputs to somebody they
don't control
they want the professor to teach the
genius of a market they hate the market
and when they grow to be big they keep
buying whoever they were dealing with
before so they could better control them
which requires them then to plan
the production and distribution of goods
inside rather than buying them in the
market
the model of the government
is it's a private corporation
i have spent my life give you an example
in american universities
big ones famous not just as a student
but as a professor i mean i've been half
a dozen school i teach now at the new
school here it's another one right
they all model themselves after
businesses
they model their
you can attack the bureaucracy of
universities good reason it's a mess
but they're proudly modeling themselves
on organizing their bureaucracy in a
business-like manner
so you're looking at a difference which
isn't there
the government and the private sector
are partners and both of them wouldn't
have it any other way the corporations
want that from the government and the
government now knows that to please the
corporations is the number one objective
they have because that's how they keep
their jobs and keep their system going
and so for all practical purposes this
is this is the same people but there's a
important differences
that
uh i don't know if they're fundamental
or just a consequence of history but if
you have government
they're accountable in a different way
than companies companies are accountable
by
especially if you have a consumer
they're accountable by sort of the
consumer spending or not spending their
money on whatever the heck the company
is selling right the government is
accountable by votes
and it seems like
government unlike companies for most of
companies history
is always too big to fail meaning it can
always just print money it can always
save itself and that creates a
bureaucracy
you never
you rarely pay the cost
of having made bad decisions if you're
in government you distribute the blame
and it's very unclear who's responsible
for bad decisions so bad decisions in
government accumulate so you become more
and more and more inefficient
and
more and more poor in your
decision-making in terms of you said
public transit should we build a public
transit system in this city or not
that's a difficult decision that's an
interesting decision uh i would say it's
very often a very good decision
but
whoever makes that decision should be
accountable for a good or bad decision
and it seems like companies are more
accountable they pay
they feel the pain
of having made a bad decision more
because it can go bankrupt they i mean
there's much more day-to-day pressure to
make good engineering decisions
government doesn't seem to be under the
same level of pressure
i is do do you disagree with that i
disagree with that
everything in my history
pushes me
you may be living i may be living in a
different uh
who knows
or taking a different sort of drug i
won't i won't mention the name but
i i personally had a lot to do with a
very large company here in the united
states here in the new york area
and um
it involved two brothers and a family
who built it up into a huge corporation
one of the brothers was
kind of the dynamo
of the family
and he was more responsible than anybody
else building it up
but he took care of his brothers he had
a nice feeling about his brother so
the one brother who could not
you know without
help tie his shoes
became a vice president
got an enormous salary
got a beautiful office in a skyscraper
uh not that many blocks from where i'm
sitting right now
and
that was the way that
family handled that company
and all of his relatives that were
somewhere in this company doing a
variety of whatever
because
in my experience with this
and because i went to the schools i told
you
all my experiences with that group of
people corporately say full of those
stories
you know
they made mistake after mistake which
they would tell you about
didn't didn't undermine their they were
always able to blame
somebody else something else
that scraped them through and had they
not been able to they would have been
replaced by another person who did the
same thing for as long as they could
and they knew it
they would talk about it at family even
that's how i know
yeah that's i mean that i understand
that you want the outside world to look
at it this way but well not my
experience interest but again what's
that kind of thing uh at the risk of
saying human nature again i wonder what
kind of system
allows for that more versus versus less
this is the question of
i would call that let's put that under
the umbrella term of corruption okay um
which system allows for more corruption
remember that the way i defined a
different system is not more or less
government it's more or less allowing a
democratic workplace yeah reconfiguring
it what what happens when everybody
has a vote when you have to explain
what the strategies are what the
alternatives are to a larger number of
people than a board of directors or
major shareholders or whoever it is that
most companies are responsible to
and now you've got a whole different
universe it's not a small group of
people can't be hidden the way it's
normally hidden most of it and on and on
and on this is you know worker co-ops is
what this is called in many parts of the
world so it's not that i'm advocating
something that's never been seen before
not at all
the marxism i understand is to
pick from historical precedence the
things that we think will work better
and i think if all the people in an
enterprise just to drive the point home
democratically decided they would never
give
two or three individuals a hundred
million dollars while everybody else
can't send their kid to college if
you're not gonna do that
you